Let's take a moment to check if
we understand how write-update
coherence works.
Suppose that a core has
a single block cache
with a valid bit,
a tag and the data, and
suppose that we have four such
cores numbered 0, 1, 2 and 3.
Suppose that core 0
reads from 700 first.
So now it gets the valid bit to be 1.
The tag is 700 and
let's say that the data rate is 6.
After this,
core 1 reads the same location.
Then, core 2 writes a value
of 17 into this location.
And finally,
core 3 reads from that location.
After all this, in core 0 what
is the valid bit in the cache?
The tag is still 700, and
what is the data that we get?
And the same for cores 1, 2, and 3.
What is the valid bit in
each of these caches, and
what's the data value placed here?
You can use this as an example, where
the valid bit is either one or zero, and
the data value in this
case is 6 after this read.
So, what's going on in these four
caches after we do this sequence?
We complete this, then this,
then this, then this.